the number one rated Cable News host in
the history of cable television Tucker
Carlson uh was out at Fox found out
about an hour before he was supposed to
be doing his show that day uh here is
Tucker
about a week later uh taken several Jabs
at the machine as well as Fox and making
an announcement on where he will show up
next
hey it's Tucker Carlson you often hear
people say the news is full of lies but
most of the time that's not exactly
right much of what you see on television
or read the New York Times is in fact
true in the literal sense it could pass
one of the media's own fact checks
lawyers would be willing to sign off on
it in fact they may have but that
doesn't make it true it's not true at
the most basic level the news you
consume is a lie a lie of the
stealthiest and most Insidious kind
facts have been withheld on purpose
along with proportion and perspective
you are being manipulated how does that
work let's see if I tell you that a man
has been unjustly arrested for armed
robbery that is not strictly speaking a
lie he may have been framed at this
point there's been no trial so no one
can really say
but if I don't mention the fact that the
same man has been arrested for the same
crime six times before am I really
informing you no I'm not I'm misleading
you and that's what the news media are
doing in every story that matters every
day of the week every week of the year
the best you can hope for in the news
business at this point is the freedom to
tell the fullest truth that you can but
there are always limits and you know
that if you bump up against those limits
often enough you will be fired for it
that's not a guess it's guaranteed every
person who works in English language
media understands that amazingly as of
tonight there aren't many platforms left
that allow Free Speech the last big one
remaining in the world the only one is
Twitter
starting soon we'll be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things to which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here free speech is
the main right that you have without it
you have no others see you soon
all right so the importance of this
situation can't be overestimated Tucker
and the amount of influence he has no
longer on Fox News corporate media now
look I basically like Fox I go on Fox
several times a week they never tell me
what to say I say whatever I want to say
and they've been good to me and it is
what it is what it is I would say from
my perspective they obviously from where
I sit made a mistake on this one uh and
I think this is really going to
strengthen say the the pond that I'm in
the independent Pond right and of course
Tucker is right like you can say a
certain amount of stuff when I do the
show every day it's the way we've always
done it and the way we will continue to
do it we try to do something that's
going to hopefully Enlighten you a
little bit maybe make you laugh a couple
times and and tell you something that is
true and every now and again the guard
rails of that uh can hit back on you
right like so if you talk about uh
vaccine mandates before they want you to
talk about vaccine mandates they could
depress you in the algorithm is YouTube
for example or if you said something
about uh if you misgendered someone in
the old regime of Twitter they could ban
you whatever it is so now new rails are
being developed
[Music]
foreign